[Laughter]
hey guys welcome to the evident game
podcast only podcast that is being
attacked currently by their cats
[Laughter]
[Music]
probably really is the only podcast at
that very moment was being literally
attacked by their cat returning back
returning back to home base up alright
guys we have a very fun podcast lined up
it is a special one it's the first one
with her like an actual guest that's not
a made-up gasp boy our cat she was kind
of our first two guest actual guest
sorry our actual non cat Bobbie Duke so
um we're gonna be we actually had this
chat with him at workbench oh yeah you
forget that very note you guys know we
just got back from workbench con a
couple days ago and while we were there
we tried to do some podcast interviews
with some cool people yeah and and we
didn't get to see as many talks but it
was it was just a great gathering of
people I think that year two it was a
little bit bigger but like it still had
that tight feel of everyone unified
around the same purpose yeah because
it's like it's not just a maker
conference it's like a maker content
creator conference that it's a very
specific it has a very strong identity
yeah so coming up over the next few
weeks we have six interviews that we're
gonna fit in the one with Bobby we
definitely went a little bit long on
this so it's gonna be this entire
podcast but all the other guests that we
interviewed and had on our show we're
gonna wrap around a topic that we talked
about and then we're probably gonna get
into our usual games and story times and
stuff yeah yeah the other interviews are
like 15 minutes so they'll just be a
portion of
usual podcast just so you guys know kind
of what's going up I also wanted to give
an update for any new listeners we are
now on every single major podcast app
and any small ones we are able to find
too so for those of you who haven't seen
one of Bobby Dukes videos I mean his
videos only have 177 million views so I
don't know I was going with that so
there's not many of you so there's not
many of you he makes some awesome videos
around art and making things and I think
that he also has a really interesting
backstory so he made his first video 11
know in 2011 and it at the time started
as more of a hobby and he was actually a
truck driver at the time which gave him
a lot of time to really think about what
he wanted to do when he started thinking
about you know could he make YouTube
work and he decided to like try to take
it seriously not just as a hobby anymore
I also think it was interesting that he
like called his cousin who's in
marketing and he got some advice that he
should probably make it short fast paced
fun referenced pop-culture things in the
very next video that he made was his
mallanna's hook video it blew up and he
was like wow I can do this the first
video that I saw what was the first one
you saw I think I think was the same one
I mean I just loved he's just like
dancing in his wig having a blast
and I really liked his goals you know he
wants to make art which he's passionate
about and he wants to make people happy
and I also thought that you know he has
a segment and in his video is called
deep thoughts with Dukie that's pretty
good me think that she should just be on
more podcasts because he he is really
thoughtful about these things and while
we chatted with him we realized that we
have like a lot of connections with him
a lot of the sense of humor and we also
bonded over doubting ourselves as
artists we talking about sponsors and
YouTube talked about working with your
significant other
there's variability I breathe out of my
nose is it gonna gonna hear my milk
because there's two wind screens on
there I'll make sure to do this pretty
loud and I get here now you just need
your beard and then we all be unified in
our beards they do the ponytail beard I
can't believe how well that beard
matches her hair perfectly and you look
just so goofy cuz you're got that smile
[Applause]
like a Russian woman like it looks good
thank you I can tell it's fake though do
you ever guys you guys ever get a hair
stuck in your teeth and you're like
wondering how it got there
like it's I'll just sound like a beard
hair stuck and like how did my beard get
in my mouth well for us it's mostly our
cat cuz she is like a wispy cat she is
like it's the finest things ever she
walks along and she leaves like that a
love like misty cat hair behind her the
down yeah yeah we've been having a lot
of troubles with our resin projects cuz
you don't you know we don't want things
in there yeah and you know she wants to
be a shop cat but she's I'm not sure
just cut out for it one time she sound
like the corner of something and got
into some goo that we don't know what it
was yeah in the corner shop we still
don't know still don't know we haven't
found him but she found some goo so you
have cat prints I almost like put on
like two pairs of jeans just like put on
my like shin guards yeah I can't imagine
I think we've ever given our cat a bath
we have one cat it's my mainly my middle
daughter latte breeze I must have forgot
Mike my kids names
it's her cat I'm allergic to cats so he
stays upstairs oh yeah her room not like
Lockton you know - he upstairs is his
domain what we found out is there's
multiple types of hypoallergenic cats
because I think I might be allergic to
some cats but if you get something like
a stinks Russia Siamese I think also
have hair but it's hypoallergenic
right strange way even I think it's
actually the dandruff there's something
in the skin of cats that sets people's
allergies oh yeah I was like inspired by
this technique his sound is so good you
can hear it because you have so
oftentimes like like people who haven't
been a lot of podcast berries in volume
and that's kind of harder to correct I'm
sure it looks dumb but I don't even have
to think about it as long as much well
another thing is some people like if
they're not videoing it they'll like
tape a mic to their nose that would
actually hilarious video podcasts
although in you Corey could get the
little like you know the what did the
boy band that's cheating though that's
cheating
so how good can I might be if it's that
big decent I mean at least like dynamic
ones another reason why we got those is
because of me and my flailing cuz I have
a tendency to range too many times with
my gestures yes but um yeah it's like
the dynamic mics are a lot more sturdy
than the condensers though like laughs
mics and stuff those are condensers if
you drop them they can break but these
let's not try to drop them Paul Jackson
was like let's do a mic drop very good
interview but I'm not sure we need a mic
drop yeah your mic yeah so I think one
of the main things we wanted to talk to
you about that I think is really
interesting you do a really good job of
balancing storytelling instruction and
humor and I'll just wanting to know like
is that something you said about
intentionally or is that something that
you've found your voice and over time as
you've made video after video kind of
it's the yes to both questions
uh-huh burp yeah both reasons answers
questions answers reasons
all three no so in the beginning its I
did put a lot of thought into how I
still put a lot of thought into what my
videos are about and what'll be in them
but yeah about the story and how to
balance information and entertainment
and keep people watching and not lose
them and you know people that are there
for like the serious learning of art and
what I'm doing in the tech yes I don't
want to lose them by being too much the
Entertainer goofiness yeah but I also
don't want to lose the people that are
there for that by the other things I'm
trying to bet and I still even know if
I'm hitting that happy medium yeah but
the whole storytelling part it just kind
of came in at just brainstorming
sessions
myself or with my wife more kids you
know just like you know this would be
really funny to add to this to just MIT
make it more funny and entertaining and
fun because that's what I'm trying to do
is make something that people can learn
from but also be entertained at the same
time you know that's the whole goal
because if you're entertained then
you're gonna have fun learning yeah yeah
you know and you may not even know
you're learning but you're going to get
information you know but also I mean
like you know we we know how fun making
can be about like I feel like a lot of
people don't oh it can be a really
intimidating yeah it can be intimidating
to especially if you see everyone doing
everything perfect and it just goes well
and it's like your step 1 step 2 step 3
and you rest on like the things you have
to do instead of like seeing people have
fun with it it's like oh the person's
having a blast yeah you know even if
something didn't go right they're having
a lot of fun and you focus on that right
you know and making is totally fun super
fun art is so much fun and it does have
its moments of man oh my gosh what am i
doing or how do I do this and just to
keep keep moving forward on it man it's
like a ride it's like this emotional
rollercoaster of certainty and knowing
what you're doing and then this like
down of like oh what am I gonna do next
and then you keep going and then you get
over that hump and then it's back up and
you're like yeah yeah you know this is
awesome fun and then it's like
frustrating and uh what you know yeah
yeah there's a lot of like
back-and-forth emotionally yeah I feel
like almost in every single project I'm
like what am i doing the resin geode
projects we like poured things out and
look like a child to draw on this yeah
you know it looks like an actual geode
yeah that's cool it's fun but I mean it
seems like whenever we talk to other
people who are doing artistic projects
almost every single one of them has
like what am i doing that's an artist I
failed
yeah yeah what was I gonna say I totally
had some dadgum train of thought as soon
as you get back to losing my train of
thought well one thing that's
interesting is as we have figured out
little parts of like what the heck we're
doing when we first started filming we
over filmed everything and we weren't
able to plan out the story as we go and
I think we've talked about a little bit
I think you film a lot extra - as you go
are you starting to like know how you're
gonna edit things and editing this in
the moment more and more or does it all
come together in the Edit and that's yes
- both as well it totally depends on the
mood I'm in if I'm having inspiration
because sometimes I'll feel like carving
yeah and I don't want to have to mess
with things I'll just set up the camera
yeah I won't really plan anything I know
I'll figure out later kind of a deal
other times it's like yes I am on charm
on Rails cuz I know what I'm doing and I
know what I want the outcome to be I can
even see the Edit in my head yeah so
those are really nice because there's a
lot less super flip super superfluous
footage yeah you know that I don't have
to mess with but before it used to be a
lot worse I still overshoot because I
like a selection you have to choose from
I was just actually talking with some
earlier I could actually re-edit almost
every single video I put out with all
new footage the same project so there
are you
we didn't fill video yeah different
video yeah same project I because I have
enough footage I've done that like
halfway before cuz there's been two
projects where we started them and then
we didn't finish them until like six
months later oh yeah as well I've done
something like that the time I I you
know we finished it I was gonna edit the
rest I was like I don't even add in that
style anymore that's the whole thing I
have a video that I started I will
complete it I don't know how long it's
been like a year and a half and
everything yet I have I have everything
I have a wonderful sword still it's it's
like 90% there it's gonna happen I
promise flash no I promise West this
year it's gonna happen this year
alright I feel horrible just you know
cuz I put it off it was one of those
things where I lost momentum and one
I'll just put another video out and then
I'll come back to it it was like I know
how much work is left on it and then you
know like but I want to keep the
consistency going and not have a huge
gap without a video and so it kept
getting more and more on the back burner
and yeah a year later and it becomes
like more and more intimidating the
longer you wait cuz you know like oh
it's gonna take
it's gonna be even more difficult to
edit yes
oh yeah I'm going to talk about how much
time has passed at the beginning to you
know and man use that as kind of a thing
like you could if you put something off
come back to it yeah you know you can
have a deep thought moment yeah deep
thoughts with the Dok yeah that's a good
point
[Music]
perfect white background - won't get
distorted yeah yeah okay see I've only
nearly do one I totally ripped that off
once because as a nod I mean you know
you did a big nod in your letter quick
aside for anyone just listening to the
audio we were making the thumbs-down
symbol in reference to the reference to
the diamond thumbs down button he made
and sent to YouTube yeah after a YouTube
rewind all right let's go back in time
yes I was like yeah just just say you
got it just reach out to your like like
your your contact there and have them
like dig through the mailroom she
doesn't go on and investigate now yeah
she's there to put a pacifier in my
mouth and nose pretend she's doing
something they don't know anything
either it's hard no YouTube yeah
managers yeah I don't know maybe I
shouldn't talk about it you know there's
probably also things that they aren't
aren't allowed to say even if they know
what they yeah I'm sure there's things
they can't it it does you frustrating I
know it was total tangent but it I'll
ask a specific question like if I do
this will get D monetize I'll look into
that and that's what she'll say
yeah and then the next time we talk it's
a yeah I'm pretty sure or I think this
she never gives me an answer cuz I don't
think they even know it's all algorithm
based so it's like AI is controlling
everything yeah that I don't think she
could give me a straight answer
well also know because it's a moving
target all the time too what's okay one
month may be different by the time
because like like the conspiracy videos
you know yeah it's it's they were okay
and now they're not that's okay and I
know someone got grandfathered in and
etc but quick aside for those of you who
haven't ventured too far outside of like
the maker videos Shane Dawson is OG
content creator and he has been blowing
up even more recently as he kind of
tackles these documentary style deeper
dives into people and topics and stuff
like that and yeah and the most recent
one was a two-part conspiracy theories
video which he released literally right
as YouTube announced the conspiracy
theory crackdown it's hilarious how
something not creepy will be happening
but he's like about the whole pizza he's
looking at this pizza like it is gone
grown eyes he's great at injecting
sensationalism and drama yeah you know
that's what he is good at but mostly
harmless way yeah is like the power of
storytelling and editing he made Jake
Paul like kind of humanized him and yeah
and kind of made you feel like well
maybe you know but then you look at the
actions they you know done it took all
that goodwill and threw it right down
the garbage disposal but but for a while
there yeah it was super powerful yeah
yeah it's it's very powerful the the
edit and the
the story - the story behind it you know
how you put things in different
perspective and frame them and
everything yeah that's why editing is so
important editing is so important thank
you thank you it is an art form and it
is the video in essentially yeah I mean
what we're making isn't the thing we're
making it's the piece of content that we
end up with that video is the end
product yeah yeah it really is
yeah and that's okay I mean the funny
thing is like I'll hand it over to me to
like throw element of chaos all the
explosions and some green things and
twirly phases and just like like kind of
give it that like bad internet feel to
do like corporate marketing for giant
huge company branding and faction school
writing the manuals and how people did
stuff so it's like I can come in and
kind of mess up a little bit and give it
a human like because too much gotten
into what you did before YouTube
full-time I'm sure your audience that
watches like we're gonna songs we don't
know I'm sorry
yeah like mechanical mechanical a lot of
a lot of mechanical design there's a
small company so I wore all the hats I
set up our servers I did the IT I did
the testing worked with the machinist
and that's one of the most valuable
things it's like going out into the shop
on the floor working with people who
know how these machines work and
everything like that that's better
education than some most college class
I'm sure that comes in handy yeah yeah
we can get a new tool and Evans like I
don't need instructions like this I'm
like okay I can make it pretty this idea
I absolutely
now the welder I had unwarranted you
confidence he breached
all of the welders that we use we're all
set up for you had unwarranted
confidence so we've done some welding
with like like JB and like well longer
and like people who really know how to
do it and they hand us everything
already set up so we are oh well then it
comes to all the settings we use the
wrong nozzle tip like because you you
choose the wire and depend on the wire
you need to have the teeth right the
mandrel riding the tip right very basic
things but we just like stuck the wire
and fed it through and thought oh it's
gonna be the hot glue gun that it's
supposed to be some very slight tweaking
and the manual might have fixed that
that's cool yeah I would love to get
into or learn I've done some very basic
literally have no idea what I'm doing
stucks couple bezel I repaired a go-kart
once if you want to learn from two
complete newbies it will be exciting
they will be exciting but there's welder
out there now that has a graphical user
interface like an LED screen right and
says what thickness of sheet are you
welding what wire are you welding well
stay in this green range right here and
don't go outside otherwise it's gonna
stink I need that we our disclaimer I
think FCC rule s is it FCC if they give
it to you or he's still supposed to say
it it's different it depends on if
you're endorsing it if you're just
saying I'm gonna be using and you're not
like stating your opinion on it yeah but
just for full disclosure yeah
just keep people informed so there's no
hey we heard that man you can go to jail
now for not disclosing and giving bias
reviews without disclosing it well yeah
it's misleading I mean to jail that's
pretty harsh yeah I mean the people may
not go to jail but like you could judges
can give that as a penalty now but I'm
glad there's accountability yeah yeah
and to be transparent in what you're
being paid to promote yeah
you know but what do they do for like I
mean I don't know if you heard about
like the beauty YouTube community
there's a lot of great ways where there
was they would like send you a
competitor's products and you would tell
you to bash them oh is that legal
someone else's product and they would've
get more on yeah well just that makes me
think of they're like Gucci I think it
was Gucci like Snooki sent all the
Jersey Shore people I might be getting
the brands wrong like Gucci bags for for
them to wear to make Gucci look bad and
then Gucci made them not to use it
no they're making money I like all
fronts
getting free stuff from one front and
getting paid interesting question or I
just had an interesting question is it
any more ethical to promote something
for money than it is to talk crap on
something for money I mean it's hard to
know but if you are genuine about it
right then it doesn't seem sketchy but
like if you're not genuine it is pretty
sketchy if you know it's wrong if you
know it's wrong and you're endorsing it
despite that then that's pretty sketchy
right like yeah I will never promote
something unless I genuinely stand
behind it would have used the thing
regardless yeah yeah but I think it's
just as immoral if you're only saying
the good things about the product is
getting paid yeah actually you think
actually don't have it
piñon about the thing is about the same
but it yeah we really you know when we
talk to people who are like growing and
it we really encourage people to reach
out to companies that you already love
because then that's such an easy it's a
it's an easy sell to the company because
you can tell the story and you your
genuine feelings show through and you
get a better people say like oh don't
reach out because our yeah they reach
out to you you have more power but then
if you reach out to them you get to pick
people into the space who aren't in this
space because we've told the story to
them and we want to tell the story to
our audience and I think that it's a win
win win win so China China China which
China the wrestler are listening audio
can't see my hands so so you do some
crazy stuff for your YouTube videos and
a lot of it's in public what's been like
the most weird looks you've got and
while doing one of those most of the
time I don't really get the pleasure of
observing their looks because I'm
looking at my phone oh yeah I'm in frame
Oh looking down videos I did Nicole off
to when I stole Jimmy's ice pick yeah I
got start to do the walk and there's I
forget some side shots to show how
stupid it actually looks yeah I've
gotten the kind of looks after I stop
and look around like people like what is
going on you know cuz in Walmart done
and in everything you just have a second
channel called the the dookie dookie is
what friends people called me when I was
younger all the time but select friends
David yeah hey Dukey what's up you know
perfect barbary Yuki yeah that was so so
what was the pose you're like journey to
like YouTube and what were some of your
inspirations when you first started well
or did you till I say I'm just gonna do
my own with blinders and stuff like that
sometimes like if I want to make a
project that I've assumed someone may
have attempted ah I won't even look to
see if it's been done yeah I don't want
to be influenced I wanted to be my
complete spin like Frost more urn on the
frost more um the Thor's Stormbreaker
yeah yeah I assumed someone had made a
replica yeah I didn't know if they'd
done it my way and that's why I wanted
to do it my way without outside
influence yeah but I absolutely look to
other channels for inspiration you know
how to be better like like Casey nice
that is a good example just the the he
uses editing purely I mean I I think
he's seems like a really nice guy but
he's not like super exuberant and crazy
much tends to be the driving force
behind a lot of channels he uses really
cool and interesting edits and it's the
environments he's shooting in and things
like that so I glean
subtleties like why what about his what
about his stuff makes him so popular and
I try to kind of dissect it and what
when I'd land on an idea that I think
might be it then I'll try to integrate a
version of it that is mine but sort of a
spin off sort of deal or like I've
watched tutorials you know interest
making transitions more interesting
something as simple as a cut from one
clip to another doing something a little
bit more interesting that's not that
important but like I like these like
whip transition
and adding a whip sound or whatever yeah
or have the transition to where like all
of a sudden like I'm rushing unto the
camera you know into the it like my face
is filling the screen that's all things
that I've experimented with but there's
been something I've seen that it's kind
of sparked that idea yeah behind it you
know they say there is no original
thought and I don't believe that good
everyone's inspired by each other the
only the reason I have inspiration at
all is because of the life I'm living
and the things I'm around and involved
in and the day to day inspiration I get
so yeah I don't really remember what the
original question was like some of like
where you start it off when you're first
starting off none of us know what we're
doing most of us still don't know what
we're doing right it's so reassuring to
hear people say that yeah every project
I start out I'm like okay where does
this thing begin and I have no idea I
mean I'm not very organized at all I
don't have like these ideas way off
occasionally I'll have one maybe two
vague ideas future projects like the one
I'm working on now like the bucket hands
this has been sitting and irritating in
my brain it needed to happen I've been
thinking about this for like a year or
two Wow
I have projects there's some that are
very big they're usually big projects
yeah I can't just get do they're ones
that are gonna take a long time so they
usually end up not being started until
I'm just like okay I have to do this
yeah yeah man I keep losing my I keep
going on these tangents sorry oh yeah
like starting one place and then finding
your style over time it seems like
that's been the common thread for a lot
of the content creators because yes no
one can just like come up with how to do
you choose your Bob Claggett unless
you're Bob
yeah no it's totally been an evolution
of you know it's been more so me being
more open with sharing my sense of humor
and my personal goofiness and the things
that I say
quickly only reserved for my family and
like you know the just silliness and you
know that's kind of stuff that's it's
been more and more of me opening up yeah
and and showing people what I think is
funny because you know what it's scary
to be vulnerable and out there and when
you can get over that and you don't
really you don't care and you're doing
it this whole thing is in a way kind of
cathartic you know yeah getting things
out and like when I do deep thoughts
with Dukie I absolutely am talking to
myself yeah I'm talking to the person
that's watching on the other end as well
because I hope it'll help them but it's
almost like I'm saying these things
because I know I need to hear them as
well so when is deep thoughts with Dukie
the podcasts gonna start up bunch of
people say I need to start about a
podcast they're like us even run ads on
it you know but I actually think it
would be cool to to do that just like a
therapy session you know yeah with ours
like we don't talk about we don't really
talk about making or the projects we
specifically we just talked about like
whatever we're feeling about stuff and
we'll like play dumb games like it is
really cathartic just a place to talk
you know at a greater length than you
can really do in a video like a project
yeah yeah okay I feel so guilty taking
up people's times in the videos you know
it's like yes is there like active time
you know you gotta like make it or
something and this was kind of a
struggle that we faced to trying to
strike a balance between like you know
trying to contain some you know useful
information or tips that might help
someone but also trying to be
entertaining but then there's also like
if you're trying to throw in more
talking and story based stuff and I like
talking to the camera then it's like
only the super hardcore fans will sit
through everything so like mixed
identity yeah but then you can expose
both sides to each other if you find the
balance yeah
you know and I think that's pretty
powerful yeah I think you really get
balanced too as well you know those like
balance balls where it's like a half
ball mm-hmm it's like like a wooden
roller in the center oh wow
those things are really fun dangerous
immediately you're either having fun or
you're like slamming onto the ground
like wildly like imagine a rolling
wooden cylinder on a board and you see
balance on the thing and it's rolling
back and forth yeah Wow I remember many
a times whacking my oh I'm sure that
that's not like legal to sell anymore it
was technically sort of an exercise
thing like a balance Oh exercise maybe
I'm wrong it was probably just a toy I'm
having fun picturing it yeah it's very
similar to those other than imagine the
ball being able to move around and yeah
I'm for it I think like we're you know
like we'll be going more towards
entertainment side of it and then like
the videos maybe aren't performing as
well because they're kind of goofy ER
and we haven't like I don't know fully
converted our audience to expect that
sometimes we might just be goofy and
we're not gonna be focusing on yeah the
project as much and then so we'll go
back the other way we're like okay we're
gonna do really hardcore build and will
still be goofy but like the build will
be more substantial and yeah yeah I
heard I think that well obviously you
can't make everyone happy yeah so really
the the best what's the word compass
that I think would be to go just do what
you think is enjoyable to you yeah and
then it'll be the most genuine and like
I did I've done a lot like hyper focus
like oh my gosh like what what what's
the the magic formula you know the
perfect balance and if I watch a video
back which half the time I don't until
after I publish it because I'm just like
so like okay I can't watch any more of
this thinkin's it's going out there okay
you know be free but after I watch it
and if if it strikes that balance with
me personally
then I think that's about that's the
best I can do I think for us that's like
the the thing we have to keep on
reminding each other and ourselves is
the whole reason why we started doing
this this is spend time together to have
fun to establish this business that we
can grow with and that can grow with us
and if we're not if we're not keeping to
that then it kind of loses the point of
why we did this path which isn't the
easy path I feel very lucky I feel very
like like we have a great opportunity in
front of us but at the same time it's
it's not the easy path
no yeah having to have creativity on tap
is stressful and can be like really
stressed because you know you ever think
of like what if we just like run out of
ideas we haven't we haven't reached that
stress yeah just like sometimes we'll
feel such a sense of urgency because
there's so many ideas that we want to
tackle them we are so excited about all
of them and we and we know we can't yeah
yeah it's like choosing which child is
your least favorite you know it's like I
guess we'll cut that one you know stuff
I have a question
so I've wondered has it made you guys
closer in your marriage you know
or does it I imagine you would have to
because you're having to literally work
together and interact all the time and
talk about ideas that yeah go over
things and and that sounds really like I
I can't think of a cooler thing to do
with my wife No so cool I think that the
main thing because I think that before
we were dating we are really good
friends we were friends for five years
before we started dating and you know
we've always kind of been each other's
best friends I think the main thing that
this has helped us refine further is the
communication nation my gosh yes
oftentimes like I'll realize that I've
been saying something wrong for the
longest period of time and just by
adding like I've been thinking whether
or not it's a good idea to instead of
I've been thinking which imply
I'm positive about something general or
big but like little thing that's like
refining there's little communication
aspects between each other I think helps
clarify thing this like because you know
this is a business yeah we're having to
do a lot of business tasks and that
means like you know some things we come
together on some things we divide and
conquer and we're like delegating things
to each other and like making really big
decisions together like I feel like it
has you know maybe like I feel like
that's something that you know is
important in any relationship being able
to like tackle those types of challenges
too and I feel like it's skills that can
be applied to like you know if we decide
to have kids one day like yeah there's a
lot of skills we develop working on this
business baby as we call it we could
apply there or you know there's so many
things yeah I think it has I mean we
were it not that we weren't close in our
marriage before like we bought it's God
of change you're done something you know
yeah yeah we wouldn't have started this
business if we like I think it really
has refined a lot of skills right yes
like you do have skills as a couple you
know it's right yeah you have to work at
it
yeah you gotta work at it I'm like I
feel like we've leveled up like we have
this really nerdy analogy or at least
maybe if you don't want to associate it
with you know but like I I think I
played a lot of role-playing games and
stuff and I think that as I go through
life I've kind of been equated things to
like a video game you know it's like
we've learned a new skill video editing
we've learned a new skill podcasting
we've learned a new skill like all sorts
of things and we keep on leveling up
ourselves and the skills and this like I
feel like this path that we're on is
level in the SUP so much faster than if
we got to stay at a normal job yeah the
skills that we have maybe just done the
same thing again and again and again
individual jobs and yeah this is like
you gotta work together
it's like powerleveling yeah yeah that's
cool I my best friend is my wife yeah
like I can't I think it would be so much
fun but a lot of work too
because you would have to get back
that's probably like the biggest
struggle we don't have many struggles in
our marriage but communication cuz she
her brain works one way my brain works a
completely different way and sometimes
it is like we're speaking two different
languages I'm like but learn learning
those languages is nice yeah I want to
speak Nicole yeah you know yeah
sometimes I'll be like really
enthusiastic about it I an idea and I
get into my like whatever calls like my
argument voice and I'm talking in a
certain way because I'm excited about it
but it's also like I'm pitching it
trying to get him on board music are you
angry those skills that you develop and
refine it really is like not all by fire
cuz like it's so great because we're a
hundred percent on the exact same team
yeah and that's a hundred percent clear
and what we've done is we've stayed
ahead of it if we're ever noticing that
we're getting upset we're like whoa
we're getting upset about something
what is it camera together you can't
just like like if you're getting
frustrated well I'll turn on the camera
and be happy together
yeah oh it's like it kind of makes you
figure out whatever that point of
tension is because it's real way cuz if
you're going to be genuine they've got
to have that resolved you can't you
can't fake
[Laughter]
so easy yes Johnson said we would've
made so much money and it's so easy but
let's let's not do any of that
yeah just like it was given to them on
about such a win yeah if you don't if
you don't know ever talk about it the
Super Bowl spongebob sale war flashbacks
[Laughter]
sorry got sidetracked by the tuba no
it's perfect it's perfect
that's how we like our podcast to go
just pick a general topic and then get
sidetracked as possible here with
anything relevant
okay we don't want to take you too much
away from all the tuba playing
Hannigan's
one thing that really definitely like
struck me is like I completely agree
with that
showing your personality on screen and
like people like wondering if you're
genuine it's like we get that question
and decent amount it's like are you guys
like we're a little bit more goofy coat
it down if you like the one thing that
we do all the time is we take a word and
we butcher it again and again and again
and tell us games Shimane games yeah
one fan that we haven't told the full
story but he'll just leave bread emojis
now it's like we instead of saying like
are you ready
we'll say are you ready and that then
that evolved to like are you bread and
then we would also any food is bread
it's start with breakfast
so like the breads bread and then and
now it's also dinner so like the breads
bread and like are you bread - bread
because the bread is bread far with us
yeah I do a lot of that with my wife but
I have this one friend Joe who we
totally we've been friends for years and
years 16 years 17 years and so that
humor has evolved where we'll start with
like some inside joke thing and it
evolves until it's a complete utter mess
but it's still hilarious but we don't
like have to remember what started this
like he calls me Java C to bow swells
and I don't really remember combining
and ABing and yeah yo javis beat you
bow-wow you see I don't you two just
making up new memes yeah yeah if I'm
being genuine they were yes I have to
like I have to tone it down well I'm a
balance well yeah so that I don't drive
them cuz I'm in like goofy dad joke
humor mode almost all the time and I
really have to tell myself okay I'm
their father I don't want them growing
up thinking my dad was all he was never
serious so I have to like make myself be
like okay I'm the father
another thing that I had the thought but
I want to go back to it it was so
interesting because hearing your process
of sometimes you just want to get the
work done in this film it and you wrap
it in later and sometimes you're
inspired to do the skits what's so
interesting is it comes across as you're
balancing it bit by bit so you go
through the montage and then the the the
bit and then the montage and the bed and
attack balances it out pretty well just
naturally I guess it's just kind of the
way it's evolved in in the way I've
decided to do it you know I do time
lapses with a little montage I try to
like inject a little so the montage
doesn't get boring you know yeah injects
sometimes some little funny bits here
and there but mmhmm yeah I like adding
the story because it just makes it fun
yeah like that's what this is all about
is having fun enjoying being creative
enjoying making things because it's so
satisfying to do that and it's fun
anyways I don't know yeah well one one
thing that's great about what we do is
everything's a story no matter what
because you start with raw materials yes
dimensional lumber and then it becomes a
big block and then it becomes hands
holding like it's a transformative story
in and of itself and then you're adding
the story on top of that so it's like I
think there's a lot of channels that
maybe are more utility based yeah we
couldn't tell like a story around the
drywall yeah when I go and I like I need
to figure out how do I change the leaf
spring or the BRIT disc brake on my
model think yeah I'm not gonna want
someone like me try and teach how to do
yeah big revelation frost it's like
we're not experts at a lot of things and
we felt uncomfortable telling people
exactly how to do this way I do we're a
hundred percent down with that yeah
I do it like this or we do it like this
okay that's just part make fail make
fail me sure that's it that's it every
single time every single time that's the
next level and I know my limits thanks
so much for coming along yeah thank you
for having me I appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
watching haven't watched Bobby Dukes
videos yet there'll be a link down in
the description to his channel and all
of his videos we're on the show notes if
you're listening to the podcast and
Bobby thanks again for joining us super
fun super fun
[Music]
alright so instead of a thing of the
week I think we have two announcements
announcements of the week announcements
of the week one is we're gonna be going
to spring make as our next event events
have just been like really fun you know
the dates of that mmm just edited him
with like a computer voice April 20
something I was right of course I
obviously know the dates is April 25th
to the 27th in Cleveland Ohio yes
definitely didn't Google it just now
definitely didn't Google it just right
now okay and I have a very important
announcement see what's crazy is I don't
know what this announcement okay okay
okay so you know in our last episode we
played two truths and a lie yes and we
gave each other three items to them or -
one was a lioness personal to guess
which one was a lie I lied about a lie
what it was unintentional I actually
remember but I was on the phone with my
mom and she was like listening to your
app your podcast episode I'm pretty sure
you've been doing offspring concert and
I was like what no and she was like yeah
you got your picture taken with Dexter
and I was like why it worked or oh I
just forgot because it was at Warped
Tour and they will see a bunch of people
and also those in high school and I
would see it's very important very
important for restoring the trust in our
marriage for you ever given for your
transgressions against our marriage
alright guys thanks so much for
listening to our podcast if you haven't
given us a review yet would really
appreciate it or just sharing with
friend or just continuing to listen you
know just you know we make it easy there
are a lot of ways to support us and our
podcast and we'll look forward to seeing
in the next one is joining a little set
of eyeballs so for those of you who
haven't seen one of Bobby Dukes videos